In this video we shall review how to configure site and scan data settings.
You can configure Burp Suite Enterprise Edition to create new sites for API generated scans.
You can also change the criteria that identify issues as new and manage whether old scans are
automatically deleted. To do so, navigate to the settings cog and select sites and scan data.
From here you can toggle whether you display sites generated by the REST API.
Additionally you can configure how to automatically delete old scans selecting from the drop downs.
This can be from one day to five years.
And finally we can determine how to configure scan deltas. So an issue is new if the issue type has
not been seen before. By default this will be anywhere on the site or you can toggle to the same URL.
Please note Burp Suite Enterprise Edition always keeps the most recent scan even if it's older than
the defined threshold. Thank you.